do you have a writing routine
so i have add and i
like really need to have complete
silence
um i also love to live in chaos
so uh i have three children
uh you know i had to have a business
that did commercials when i was writing
this
i you know have a day job
i have you know tons of stuff going on
so what i
try to do is i try to get up around five
or six and start writing for
a good two or three hours in the morning
before the rest of the world wakes up
and my phone starts to buzz
or my kids wake up and then
i do the same thing at night i
will start again at 7 00 pm
and work until about 12 or 1. and
so that it's really like i don't know
how
how to turn the world off unless the
world is usually asleep
um so that that's that's kind of my
my i mean that's that's
that's how i find time to write i guess
it's not necessarily like my
you know initial style um
i'll take you know i'll take a you know
with this this was more of a rewrite but
if i'm writing something from scratch
it's like
you know i'll take an idea i'll try to
write a scene
i'll take that scene and say
okay now i have to like how does this
get to where it is
you know i usually if i'm going into a
script and saying okay this
i'm going to write this you know into a
movie
i usually kind of know how it i want it
you know roughly
how it's going to unfold or end
and i have something in either the
middle or the beginning
and then it's like finding that journey
kind of gluing everything together
so i take those few hours that i'd have
in the morning and a few hours that i'd
have
at the end of the day and
you know journey down those stories and
do outlines
i try to do outlines they don't
necessarily always work for me sometimes
just getting into scenes and writing
them and writing more scenes and writing
more scenes
works and throwing away you know
60 percent of those scenes 75 of those
scenes that i've already written
um all helped me kind of find a
character and
what they are i would say in the writing
process i threw
i didn't i i probably only threw away
three scenes written uh
my producer and editor partner will hate
that he's always like
how many we didn't cut any scenes from
the film and i'm like yes we did we cut
this he was like that's half a scene i'm
like
that's that's half the scene that's a c
um but you know my process
i would say that that would be my
process it's like i have a few hours
i try to i try to map out something
uh i've done the classes i've done the
robert mckees and you know i've you know
i've tried to kind of go
okay what's the best method and you know
i think every writer has to kind of find
like how their brain works um
it's not something that you can just
take out of a book and say okay
i'm going to do this outline and then
there's a positive and negative charge
of everything i do
and like everything ends up this way and
like what
you know you know i'm going to draw a
map and i'm going to have
all this you know you know this this map
this roadmap is going to get me from
point a to point b
um that works for a lot of people i mean
there's there's just a lot of ways i
mean filmmaking and
movie i mean filmmaking in general is
just there's so many paths and so many
ways to do
any of it that you have to kind of find
the best one that works for you
you know or else you're just kind of
making yourself you're also just trying
to
do what everybody else does or you're
just trying to kind of fit into
you know another another person's method
and i think that learning those methods
are good but every time i've learned a
method i
it i never quite do it exactly that way
i just take that one bit that really
works for me
and say okay that that part that that
works for my brain because my brain
you know not everybody's brain works the
same way
um you know focus
writing i mean sometimes i can start
writing and i i won't stop and it'll be
until 2 a.m
and sometimes you know getting starting
writing is is impossible but
you know it's a very very hard task and
then
in the end you you have a script
and you you've lived with it for so long
that you need somebody else to be like
this is really good or say
this isn't really good and then you have
to go back and do it again and to have
and and you have to keep telling
yourself like okay this idea is good and
i just haven't worked hard enough
to kind of get it to be good
and you have to be careful in some
places because sometimes you know you
have to have
somebody in your life who's going to
tell you the truth
uh as a writer
if you don't have somebody that's going
to tell you the truth
a lot of people want to say this is good
you know a lot of people want to go like
yeah i liked it you know and
you really want to find the person
that's going to kind of call you out
and say yeah it's not
you know i didn't understand this or i
didn't get this or i didn't do this but
there's just a lot of you know i've been
brought scripts
i've been i've been
you know hand i've been handed scripts
and i've told people you know
truthfully like look i don't think i
don't think this is right i don't think
it's
done i think you need to keep going and
people have had to say that to me
and i have def i definitely have a few
people in my wheelhouse i'm always like
you read this will you read this because
you know
there's other people who i have that
read things that are that love
everything and i'm like
um i don't trust you i don't trust that
you
are telling me the truth you're not
trying to hurt my feelings i don't want
that
i want you to hurt my feelings but
on the flip side though then there's
also people that that's all they want to
do so how do you know that this person's
really telling you the truth
not just sugar coating something but
also not
trying to stop you from something you
don't
i mean you don't you have to trust your
source you have to know your source is
that somebody who's going to do that
you know uh
i'm trying to think if there's like a
you know there's never a silver bullet
in any of the in
any of this industry um so
[Music]
you know you want somebody you want
somebody who has
taste who's your friend
and sometimes your friends don't have
taste
so you just have to keep trying uh
because
uh you know you can you can say
you know and then sometimes that person
that you're like okay this is the this
is the magical person who has taste
and is and will will will tell me
exactly if it's good or if it's bad
now i have to get that person to
actually read it which is
one of the hardest parts about being a
writer is that you send the script out
to people
and they'll go oh yeah i'll get i'm
going to get to that this weekend like
oh i
i have a plane and i'm going to do this
on the plane
and you know it's one of the it's harder
as a writer it's hard as a director i
mean
getting you know we live in a world
where people would rather
kind of flip pictures through a book uh
instead of reading an entire script but
you get people to read that script and
once they read it you know when it's
good because you can tell
their response um
i mean you gotta smell the [ __ ]
sometimes if someone says it's great
and you know they can't mention anything
about the script
then they probably didn't read it and if
someone says you know oh i do you know
it's the same thing you always kind of
have to
like if someone thinks something is
really good they're going to give you an
example
they're going to give you something
that's like the scene
where the guy grabbed grabbed the knife
and like hit it and then she didn't know
and do you know that's when you're like
okay that person has read my script
you know and you'll be you know i've
been in so many meetings with financiers
and they're like
yeah well i don't know about this and i
was like did you read the script they're
like no but i i get it i get the script
i get it so
that's that's what their producers
always tell me like i just
don't don't get mad at them for not
reading the script
do you think you're a better writer with
chaos around you you know you hear about
like charles bukowski and you can see
from documentaries that his office was
a mess but he thrived in that
environment
or a philip k dick he had a place that
he called the hovel
which was his dirty apartment and he
could do his best work there
you think you thrive better riding under
chaos and
or or it's just sort of whenever it fits
into your schedule or in the early
morning late at night
no i actually think i i write better
not in chaos but i
come up with idea i mean i just that's
just my life i love to like live in
chaos i just think that
life if you let life kind of keep
happening
and doing things like that's where
good ideas come from or like you get to
the bottom of like how people feel about
things
uh you know raw emotions come out and
you know chaotic things are happening
and i think that's where you find out
about kind of
character uh and um
kind of human nature um
and just kind of fun ideas like things
that you
you know you're like oh yeah you can't
write about that but i need to actually
physically write it down and to give it
dialogue and to give it kind of
structure i need everything to kind of
be
quiet i don't need a dirty place
i just need a quiet place where no one
can kind of bop their way in
where i can move around walk around a
bit
or i need a like
or i sit at a bar with like
noise-cancelling headphones in where i
can't like hear i can hear
people's conversation but not really
and you know a good stiff drink
but like sometimes that amount of chaos
they have a guy if i don't know anybody
there
sometimes that really you know does uh
do well
just sitting there and kind of like not
knowing who
who's around me and what it is and like
i can get in and start writing but
you know i don't think it's for me it's
not about like
being in a special den or uh
you know little nook or or you know just
some place that i can just go okay
this is my couch this is my desk
i usually move back and forth between a
desk or a couch
be it an office or my house or anything
and uh you know just quiet
nobody can walk in and and stop it i
think it's the thoughts
it's the thoughts during the chaos that
i i like log and go
oh that's how somebody would react like
if you push somebody this way
they react this way like and that's what
what i think helps
it helps me as a writer when you're at
the bar with the headphones on do you
have people
trying to get your attention and hey
buddy what are you doing there or you
know
how are you able to uh keep in your own
little world there
no i just you know you find some
good wooden irish bar that like not
not everybody's there to kind of meet or
talk to anybody else
i mean that that's you know i don't do
that a lot but i have done some great
writing in those moments
um uh but i i
found and i do this as a director that
if you have over-the-ear headphones
people don't go up to you as much
because they're these blatant things
like i don't want to
listen to you i'm i'm doing something
else
you know i did that when i was actually
on the set of nurse jackie because i
knew the crew so well
i would i need to do a shot list
and i would need to kind of plan my
shots and i'd always like to play you
know plan
like you know specific shots out for
scenes and
you know i'd go onto the set and
sometimes some they'd be shooting a
different episode and
you know a lot of the crew guys would
come up and be like hey man like how you
doing
and i was like good and then like once i
put these big headphones on
i was just like there and they would be
like
am i like put some nice music on i was
like oh this is great i could just uh
nobody bothers me today i'll think you
know they'll realize i'm working
like i'm doing something here so
you